各位同学
我们今天上的课程很特别哦
我们要聊一下诗丝跟歌词是不一样的
歌词是可以入月的
而丝不行
因为诗的结构
它的形式
他的段落
他的韵脚他是不适合这
直接入月的
但是今天特别要讲诗的原因
是因为其实施也是我们创作的一个养分
特别是现代诗
也是所谓的诗歌
那在此分享一下我创作的一种文字类别
叫素颜韵脚诗
同学们记得哦
我们可以从别人的歌词作品里面去获取
技巧跟创意
我们可以从古典诗词里面去截取它的养分
它的深度
但是呢文字的视野跟文字观看事物的角度
那我们就必须从诗里面去获得
所谓的诗歌
会让我们对文字的排列组合有不同的视野
有不同的切入角度
这个很重要
因为诗的文字解净度很高
是我们吸收的一个养分
同学们
除非你有固定的作曲
一个partner
或是你是因为某个比赛去投稿
否则有时候你歌词写下来
他基本上没有入夜的话
他不是完整的作品
但是你写诗就不一样
你可以自己训练自己
除了韵脚表
然后去收集韵脚的一个数据库
还有呢主题式的一个收集词汇
这个都是工具书
记得工具书
工具书跟你必须吸收的东西是两回事
你去创作歌词的当下也同时写诗
它的好处在于说
纵使你写下的歌词一时间不能入月
变成一个有完整生命的歌曲
但是你写的诗是完整的
他的文字作品落笔当下
它的结构它就已经是有生命的了
这个章节是带领各位同学去领略诗的美
而且诗文字结构跟歌词的不一样在哪里
除了写歌词之外
你也开始写诗
因为诗会变成诗集
会变成你自己文字的记录
是你个人的文字日记
因为诗是反映个人的心态
是个人的心情
他比较像日记
只是你用诗的语处去写
而且你这个诗集里面如果漂亮的句子
到时候如果有个时间
如果有个专案
如果刚好有个机会
你可以借来用自己的作品借来用
不算抄袭吧
所以写歌词的闲暇私语也不妨开始练习写诗
接着我跟各位同学介绍的是
我写诗的一个格式叫素颜韵脚诗
素颜韵脚诗是我自己创作的一个诗的类别
因为我的诗里面没有标点符号
没有阿拉伯数字
没有外来语
竖着一张纯净的汉字的脸
然后呢诗句的行进间某种程度有压着韵脚
让诗有个节奏感
有个聆听度
所以这个是我应该说
我推广的一种诗的写作风格
待会会介绍我念几首诗给大家听
你就会知道说文字的力量有多大
有个叫韩汉的诗人写了一首诗叫重量
他是这样子写
他将带血的头颅放在生命的天平上
让所有苟活着都失去了重量
是很惊讶
直接打中了你的心
他是写给一个为了革命事业而牺牲的一个烈士
叫张志新
短短的几行字
他切中了你的心
把带血的头颅放在生命的天平上
一放它就倾斜了嘛
让所有苟活者都失去了重量
这个就是诗的魅力
简单扼要
而且有力量
另外一首诗是北岛的
叫波兰来客
诗的名字
那时我们有梦
关于文学
关于爱情
关于穿越世界的旅行
如今我们深夜饮酒
杯子碰到一起
全都是梦破碎的声音哦
年轻的梦
年轻的理想执行不了了
诗的魅力就是这样子
几行字就打动你的心
所以呢切记丝可以作为我们鸽子的养分去吸收
而且这样子的吸收会训练你对文字的精简度
接下来我介绍几位诗人的作品
让大家知道诗的魅力在哪里
一个就是席慕容
席慕容的诗基本上有某些字句是有押韵脚的
我大概国中的时候
高中的时候常常看他的无怨的青春啊
七里香什么的
那就说哇这个文字好轻巧哦
没那么厚重
没那么生命的那种控诉都没有
它是很清清淡淡的一种女生的语法去形容爱情
形容生命
那我阅读起来就很清新
就印象很深刻
跟各位分享的这首诗叫一棵开花的树
如何让你遇见我
在我最美丽的时刻
为这我已在佛前求了500年
求他让我们结一段尘缘
佛于是把我化成一棵树
长在你必经的路旁
阳光下慎重地开满了花
朵朵都是我前世的盼望
当你走近
请你细听
那颤抖的叶是我等待的热情
而当你终于无视地走过
在你身后落了一地的朋友啊
那不是花瓣
是我凋零的心
就是你去阅读是有个好处
它开拓了你对文字的视野
哇
好美哦
文字可以美成这样子去
吸收他
记得我们是歌词创作班
任何的养分
我们都需要
接下来我分享一首郑愁予的错误
我打江南走过
那等在季节里的容颜
如莲花般开落
东风不来
3月的柳絮不飞
你的心如小小的寂寞的城
恰若青石的街道
向晚琼音不响
3月的春帷不揭
你底心是小小的窗扉
紧掩我达达的马蹄是个美丽的错误
我不是归人
是个过客
他这首错误蛮有名的
罗大佑
我曾经把这首诗入乐谱成一首流行音乐
像他最后面写的
我达达的马蹄是个美丽的错误哦
记得是美丽的错误哦
所以他才会接我
不是归人
是个过客
而且达达的马蹄又呼应了第一第一句话
我打江南走过
而且他第二行是写那等在季节里的容颜
如莲花般开落
用莲花来形容容颜是不是很凄美
这个就是诗给我们的开拓性的一种文字
想象诗的语法跟结构
它会比较有画面感
它会比较有开拓性
仿佛进入了另一个文字的世界
接下来我们分享一首夏雨的短诗
叫爱情会蛀牙
写首诗很短
念给你听
拔掉了还疼一种空洞的藤
就是只是这样很短
仿佛爱情是不是很特别
就说他最后峰回路转
就是你治牙疼的时候时间很短
但是就像某一些爱情一样
就是
很快的来散的
用爱情
仿佛爱情就觉得哦
原来诗的一种文字上的结构跟语法
是可以这样子玩
可以这样子去挑战
记得如果喜欢下雨的诗
就是夏天的下雨
宙的雨就去分享
接下来分享一首顾城的短诗
在我想当诗人的时候
我就失去了诗
在我想当一个人的时候
我就失去了自己
而当你什么都不想要的时候
一切如期而来
是不是特别形容事物的语法
这个就是诗
所以呢北岛顾城席慕容夏雨正愁雨
推荐给大家这些诗人的作品
但还有更多只是说这些是我自己喜欢的诗人
那最后跟各位同学分享
是我自己写的韵脚诗
否则说了老半天
到底韵脚是长怎样好
那我简单的分享几首
这首比较短
叫职位
只为让你在生命中有过我的记忆
只为在灰烬前仍让你看见我短暂而璀璨的美丽
只为与你在篝火前相遇
在没有星光的漆黑夜里
我用一把火烧掉自己
就说你最后的目的跟手段就是希望他看你一眼
那是悲剧的爱情啊
所以我干脆我就一把火烧掉自己好了
起码最后的光临有注意到我了
但是这是悲剧
这个就是诗歌的好玩或是诗歌的文字技巧
它可以无限的去扩充它的意涵
接下来再分享一首比较长一点的韵脚诗
这首素颜韵脚诗叫做有谁看见我的日记
连字的笔画都力求秀气
我在找一些剪裁得意的句子
以便让自己更适合你
已经很久没有在月光下呼吸
怕夜里不断飞舞的过去
于是我不得不将整本都锁在抽屉
除了迷恋你的广告标题
这城市没有留下任何有关我的线索
只剩下梦还沉沦着不愿死去
最终梦衰老的无从起身离开
有谁看见我的日记
我需要爱上你之前的那些回忆
这个诗的意思是
这个人跟那个人谈恋爱之后
他基本上没有自己了
他找不回自己了
所以他需要爱上他之前的那些回忆
他像那些回忆回来
而这些回忆就是他的日记
就是他的思绪
就是他以前的他以前的自己
但是他再也找不回来了
诗的语法就是这么的巧妙
这么的细腻
这次带来的最后一首新诗
也就是素颜韵脚诗
这是我创作诗的一种写作风格
我把它赋予一个名词叫素颜韵脚诗
就是竖着一张纯汉字的脸
而且没有标点符号
那这首诗叫17岁
那一年
麻雀声被折叠起来喂食
夏天蝉鸣被搅拌涂抹在墙角有阴影的那一面
教室中
这两题关于回忆的随堂测验
你说安静得不像我们的
从前剩下咀嚼后呕吐出的残余血谷
应该无比鲜艳
而阳光位移的瞬间
地上黑压压
四散而飞的喧哗是你我以为的初恋创作的当下
其实我用一些隐喻法
一些拟人法
像麻雀声被折叠起来喂食夏天
这整个就是很有诗的语法结构
麻雀声他是听觉
怎么怎么能被折叠起来呢
然后第二句蝉鸣被搅拌涂抹在墙角
有阴影的那一面
蝉鸣也是听觉啊
麻雀声可以被折叠
蝉鸣可以被涂抹在墙壁上
这个是诗的语法
这种文字的张力也只有诗可以体现
教室中这两题关于回忆的随堂测验
记得我第三行把整个意境拉回来了
而不是那么的超现实
为什么呢
我讲到两题
麻雀声被折叠起来是一体
蝉鸣被涂抹搅拌在墙角是一体
就说你在校园的时候
操场或者是校园的周遭
即使你听得到麻雀
夏天的时候听得到蝉鸣
所以这两个听觉基本上是跟回忆有关
是跟青春有关
然后下一行我写
你说安静的不像我们的从前
这是一个反讽
这两个明明就有听觉
但是你又说这个很安静
不像我们的从前诶
那就奇怪了
那你们的从前是什么
或是我们所有的从前是指什么
下面就继续写
剩下咀嚼后呕吐出的残余血谷应该无比鲜艳哦
夏天最炙热的夏天
它咀嚼呕吐出的残余血谷
它到底吃的什么东西
但是既然是吃进去再吐出来一次
是像雪一样的无比鲜艳
所以后面写应该无比鲜艳
而阳光位移的瞬间
阳光像影子嘛
它会位移嘛
而阳光位移的瞬间
地上黑压压四散而飞的喧哗
像你我以为的初恋哦
原来他们的初恋是一场彼此的猜忌
彼此的以为他搞不好
这男的说你你星期六有没有空去看店
他就以为哦他喜欢他了
这是初恋的南方
搞不好去的时候搞怕一群哥们
谁知道
就说每个人对青春的解读不一样
所以最后面我才写说地上黑压压
四散而飞的喧哗
像你我以为的初恋
就是两个人认知的初恋是不一样的
然后题目叫17岁那一年写诗的时候
诗的名字很重要
有时候诗的名字是决定了丝结构的分布
跟它的肌理的文字肌理的生长
因为有时候丝的名字遮起来
你不见得能领领略出
这是在描述什么
但是一看到诗的名字哦
17岁那一年哦
这是在子青春指青春时期的一个回忆
这就是写诗的一种乐趣
因为诗可以无止境的没有边界的
将你的想象力落实为文字
然后文字又记载了你天马行空的创意
而且不受拘束
歌词是受拘束的文字哦
通常都是先有曲后有词
所以作者也叫填词
写歌词
你是要依附着旋律去生长你的故事线
而且要跟制作人开会
要跟歌手商量
然后而且还符合作曲者的曲风跟结构
他是诗相对而言比较自由
所以虽然我们是歌词创作班
但是我很鼓励各位同学
一方面学习歌词的过程中
你也不妨写诗
这个诗任何形式都可以
而且刚刚有介绍一些我比较欣赏的诗人的作品
因为写诗的过程中可以帮你的创意留下记录
帮你的视野开阔了文字的空间
而里面的家具段落
甚至将来可以拿来当歌词的使用
这是很好的一种习惯
所以同学们记得写歌词的过程中
不妨也开始写诗歌
因为诗跟歌词不一样
丝比较多元
它的题材
它的空间性可能性比较大
所以你要训练你自己
有能力掌握掌控你笔下的文字的生长
无形中会增强了你填词的功力
记得哦加油